[Musique]
suivez-moi, vous devez voir quelque chose de
spécial tout le monde est fait d'histoires
et toutes ces histoires sont ici
dans le livre de la vie mais la plus grande
histoire commence le jour du jour
où les esprits passent entre les mondes et
tout peut arriver
regardez leurs deux meilleurs amis nous aimons la
même fille vous agissez tous les deux comme toujours
nous le faisons que diriez-vous d'un petit pari parier que
Maria épousera très bien Joaquin selon
les anciennes règles le pari est envoyé une
commande c'est tellement beau je vais perdre
poids tu répares ça pour moi vieil ami je
ne suis peut-être pas le héros du temps Maria mais je
jure de tout mon cœur que je n'arrêterai jamais d'
aimer rappelez-vous n'essayez pas de
tout prendre en même
temps c'est incroyable chaque PSS aggraver
tout-vous-  peut-manger ma dame s'il vous plaît aidez-moi à
retrouver l'amour de ma vie si vous
remplissez ces tâches, vous reverrez Maria
le livre de la vie oh je sais exactement
quoi jouer wow qui l'a totalement captivée
[Musique]